Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Although in 1914 Thomas Cook's evacuated 6,000 tourists who were stranded in Europe, they continued sending tour groups to unaffected parts of France, particularly the Côte d'Azur,
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周独家加更节目、无广告收听体验、抢先收听各系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要获取加更节目、抢先收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在 App 内订阅。尽管托马斯·库克（Thomas Cook）在1914年撤离了滞留在欧洲的6,000名游客，但他们仍继续向法国未受影响的地区（特别是蔚蓝海岸）发送旅游团，
which was advertised as being fashionably uncrowded due to world events, the poet A.E. Houseman paid his first ever visit to the Riviera in 1915 when the invention of holidays in the modern sense, tourists, which Dominic, I know you're a big fan of as well. We both unreservedly recommend, do we not? We do indeed. And we were talking a lot about it last time, when we, the invention of Victorian tourism. We've done the 18th century,
这里在当时的世界局势下被宣传为“时尚且不拥挤”。诗人A·E·豪斯曼（A.E. Housman）于1915年首次访问了里维埃拉，当时现代意义上的假期和游客诞生了。多米尼克，我知道你也是这方面的超级粉丝。我们俩都毫无保留地推荐，对吧？确实如此。我们上次谈了很多关于这个话题，当时我们讨论的是维多利亚时代旅游业的发明。我们讲了18世纪，
we've done the 19th century. So we thought that, you know, we'd really unsettle and surprise you by doing the 20th century and maybe even go into the 21st century. Who knows? We're very unimaginative on this podcast. But Dominic, so we're now very much moving into your period, your era of expertise. And I know that you've written about tourism in the 50s, 60s, 70s, 80s. So very much looking forward to what you have to say about that. But before that, we got in the previous episode to the First World War,
我们讲了19世纪。所以我们觉得，通过探讨20世纪甚至可能延伸到21世纪，真的会打破大家的常规认知，给你们一个惊喜。谁知道呢？我们这个播客非常缺乏新意。但是，多米尼克，我们现在非常正式地进入了你的专长时期、你的研究领域。我知道你写过关于50、60、70和80年代旅游业的文章。所以非常期待你对此的高见。但在那之前，我们在上一集里讲到了第一次世界大战，
Lucy Lethbridge's extraordinary fact that people, I had no idea that people were still going on holiday to the south of France throughout the First World War. Incredible, isn't it? Who knew? So Dominic, the First World War, the beginning of the last episode, we looked at the way in which when the Napoleonic Wars come to an end, people from Britain flood across the Channel and visit the continent.
露西·莱瑟布里奇（Lucy Lethbridge）提到的那个非同寻常的事实：人们——我完全不知道——在整个第一次世界大战期间居然还在去法国南部度假。太不可思议了，对吧？谁能想到呢？所以，多米尼克，第一次世界大战——在上集的开篇，我们探讨了拿破仑战争结束后，英国人如何蜂拥跨越海峡去参观欧洲大陆。
They go to the Battle of Waterloo, don't they? The site of Waterloo. They do. And the same thing happens pretty much after the end of the First World War, doesn't it? Yeah, it does, absolutely. So I think what you have is two different kinds of tourism. You have, I mean, we talked before in our podcast about the end of the first world war
他们去参观滑铁卢战役遗址了，对吧？滑铁卢的遗址。是的。基本上，第一次世界大战结束后，情况也是如此，对吧？是的，确实如此。所以我觉得，你会发现有两种不同类型的旅游业。我的意思是，我们在之前的播客中讨论过一战结束时……
we talked about kipling's wonderful short story the gardener incredibly moving short story about a woman who goes to visit the grave of um as we think her nephew in flanders obviously there were lots of trips organized for people to go to cemeteries and people to go to kind of pay their respects on the battlefields and so on but there's also just as in with Waterloo and we talked about in the last podcast there are people who are sort of ghouls who are going to see the the battlefields I suppose you would say are they ghouls I mean I mean are people going today ghouls I suppose they're not but I think there's something slightly different about going in 1919, Tom, don't you?
我们谈到了吉pling（吉卜林）那篇绝妙的短篇小说《园丁》（The Gardener），这是一个极其感人的短篇小说，讲述了一个女人去参观我们认为是在法兰德斯的她侄子的坟墓。显然，当时组织了许多行程，供人们去墓地、去战场上寄托哀思等等。但除了这些，就像滑铁卢战役一样——我们在上一期播客中也谈过——还有一些人像食尸鬼一样去参观战场，我想你会这么说吧？他们是食尸鬼吗？我是说，现在去的人是食尸鬼吗？我想他们不是，但我认为在1919年去，感觉还是有些不同，汤姆，你不觉得吗？
But maybe you want to see the scene of great events. I mean, if you've been reading about it, perhaps. No, I think you're probably. Maybe I'm being a little bit harsh. Maybe I am being too harsh. But people are being, you know, people go to watch bodies being dug up out of shell craters and things. I mean, that, I don't know. I think that is probably a little bit ghoulish.
但也许你想去亲眼看看伟大事件发生的现场。我是说，如果你一直在阅读相关历史的话，也许吧。不，我想你大概……也许我有点太严厉了。也许我真的太严厉了。但人们确实在……你知道，人们去看尸体从弹坑里被挖掘出来之类的事情。我是说，那——我不知道。我想那可能确实有点像食尸鬼的行径。
I mean, certainly I won't be, you know, I wouldn't be planning that as a family holiday. No, myself. But obviously the First World War, by and large, I would say it's an interruption. I mean, obviously for most people, they're at the front or they're kind of working overtime at the factory.
当然，我绝不会把这安排为一次家庭度假，我是说，我自己不会。但显然，总的来说，我认为第一次世界大战是一次中断。我的意思是，很显然，对大多数人来说，他们在前线，或者在工厂里加班加点。
They don't have the money. They can't travel because of blockades or whatever. So for a lot of people, this is not a great – the 1910s are not a great holiday period. But then after, once you get into the 1920s, you get a lot of trends that had started in the late Victorian or the Edwardian period really kind of coming to fruition. So obviously still most people in Britain do not have statutory holidays.
他们没有钱。由于封锁或其他原因，他们无法旅行。所以对很多人来说，这不是一个好时期——20世纪10年代并不是一个适合度假的时期。但随后，一旦进入20世纪20年代，你就会发现许多在维多利亚时代晚期或爱德华时代开始的趋势真正开花结果了。所以很显然，在英国，大多数人仍然没有法定假日。
So that's not going to come in until the late 1930s. So for manual workers, for example, I mean, they're not something, if you're sort of self-improving and earnest and sort of high-minded and so on and so forth, you may have signed up to a kind of travel club. And those started in, I would say, probably the 1880s. One of the most famous ones is the – so, Tom, you must be familiar with the travel agency Lund Poly, which was quite successful when we were children and teenagers. So they had those adverts where the end people would say lun poly get away and the person would kind of vanish so
因此，法定假日直到20世纪30年代末才会出现。所以对于体力劳动者来说，例如，这些都不是……如果你是一个自我提升、认真、思想高尚等等的人，你可能已经注册了一个某种旅行俱乐部。而这些俱乐部始于，我想大概是18世纪80年代。其中最著名的之一是——所以，汤姆，你一定对“朗·波利”（Lund Poly）这家旅行社很熟悉，在我们还是儿童和青少年的时候，它相当成功。他们当时有这样的广告，广告结尾人们会说“朗·波利，逃离日常”（Lun Poly get away），然后那个人就会凭空消失，所以……
it's called lun poly because it's the merger of two different travel agencies one of which was the the polytechnic touring association i did not know that which organized incredibly high-minded group outings so dominic we is is, I mean, this is, again, part of a continuum with Thomas Cook, who was a high-minded teetotaling Baptist. It's exactly part of that continuum. Yeah, it's appealing to, I would say, an even more sort of high-minded group of people.
它之所以叫朗·波利，是因为它是两个不同旅行社的合并，其中之一是理工学院旅游协会（Polytechnic Touring Association）。我以前不知道这一点。它组织了思想极其高尚的集体出游。所以，多米尼克，这——我的意思是，这也是托马斯·库克的延续，托马斯·库克是一个思想高尚、滴酒不沾的浸礼会教徒。这完全是这种连续性的一部分。是的，它吸引的群体，我想说，是一群思想更加高尚的人。
I mean, I'll be frank. We talked in the last episode about how horrible it would be to go to a German spa in the 19th century and drink this disgusting water and all that. To me, what would be even worse would be to go on an outing with the Holiday Fellowship or the Workers' Travel Association in the 1920s and spend my evening singing folk songs and discussing the novels of Virginia Woolf, which is what tourists are expected to do. Would you like to go to the Norwegian fjords and do that with your fellow travellers? Do you know, I think it would make a kind of wonderful reality TV show
坦白说吧。我们在上一集里谈过，在19世纪去德国温泉疗养院，喝那些恶心的水，诸如此类的事情有多么糟糕。对我来说，更糟糕的是在20世纪20年代参加度假团契（Holiday Fellowship）或工人旅行协会（Workers' Travel Association）的远足，把我的晚上花在唱民歌和讨论弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫的小说上——这就是对游客的要求。你愿意去挪威峡湾和你的同伴们一起做这些吗？你知道吗，我觉得这会是一个绝妙的真人秀节目，
to send you off on one of those, to try and recreate one. Because there was a big craze for that, wasn't there? People living in Iron Age villages or servants in country houses, that kind of thing, or 1940s house. You could go off on the 1920s walking tour. I'd pay good money to watch that. So this is also the year of camping. Yes. So how does that begin? So again, that's non-conformists, kind of political radicals, back to nature.
把你送去参加其中一个旅行团，试着重现当年的场景。因为当时对这种活动有一种狂热，不是吗？人们住在铁器时代村庄里，或者在乡村别墅里扮演仆人，诸如此类，或者体验1940年代的住宅。你可以去参加1920年代的徒步旅行。我会花大价钱看这个。所以这也是野营的年代。是的。那么这又是怎么开始的呢？所以，这也是非国教徒、某种政治激进分子、“回归自然”运动。
So all the kind of people that George Orwell is rude about. Prune drinkers. Exactly. In that George Orwell podcast, we read with great, well, I read with great relish, that section where George Orwell attacks sort of left-wing people, his fellow left-wing people. And he says, nature cure quacks, feminists, nudists,
所以，所有乔治·奥威尔（George Orwell）会出言刻薄对待的那类人。喝西梅汁的人。没错。在那个乔治·奥威尔的播客里，我们带着极大的——好吧，我是带着极大的兴致阅读了那一小节，乔治·奥威尔在其中抨击了左翼人士，也就是他的同僚左翼人士。他说，自然疗法骗子、女权主义者、裸体主义者、
fruit juice drinkers, sandal wearers. They are precisely the people who are on these holidays. At the beginning of the 20th century, they are singing folk songs. They are walking in woods with shorts. But Dominic, Dominic, to play devil's advocate, you're a worker in a factory. Yeah. You know, you're breathing in filthy air all day. It's backbreaking.
果汁饮用者、凉鞋穿着者。他们正是参加这些假期的人。在20世纪初，他们在唱民歌。他们在穿着短裤在树林里散步。但是，多米尼克，多米尼克，为了辩论起见，假设你是一个工厂工人。对。你知道，你一整天都在呼吸污浊的空气。这工作繁重。
It's exhausting. It's relentless even you surely in that situation would enjoy the chance to breathe in the fresh clean air of a field wouldn't you well maybe i would but they i don't think the people who are going on these trips are ordinary workers and factories trades unionists are they i think they're very very high-minded and sort of um they're the fabian society are they fabian they're very, very high-minded and sort of... They're the Fabian Society, are they? They're a bit Fabian. So there would be some trade unionists maybe,
这令人精疲力竭，甚至没完没了。在这种情况下，你难道不一定会享受呼吸田野里新鲜干净空气的机会吗？好吧，也许我会，但我不认为去参加这些旅行的人是工厂里的普通工人，是工会成员，对吧？我觉得他们思想非常非常高尚，某种程度上……他们是费边社（Fabian Society）的吗？费边社？他们思想非常非常高尚，某种程度上……他们是费边社的吗？他们有点费边社的作风。所以也许会有一些工会成员，
and particularly if the trade unions had organised such an outing, I think there would probably be less folk singing and more... Drinking of... Maybe drinking of real ales or something. But that I could live with. The other stuff with the sandals and the nudism, I could not live with. But camping is part of that world. So camping is absolutely part of this sort of – it's very cooperative in spirit.
特别是如果工会组织了这样的远足，我想可能唱歌会少一些，而……喝……也许会喝一些真正的爱尔啤酒之类的。那个我还能接受。至于穿凉鞋和搞裸体主义的那些破事，我可受不了。但露营是那个世界的一部分。所以露营绝对是这种圈子的一部分——它具有强烈的合作精神。
It's very politically radical. You're surrounded by people who are talking about philanthropy and about building utopia and stuff. And I think camping still slightly has that maybe i'm maybe campers listening to this will be offended but i think it slightly has that tinge doesn't it there's a sort of high-mindedness yeah perhaps yes although there's glamping now isn't there which is basically like living in a very posh hotel i could do glamping but not um yeah but i'll tell you what it's really. So what also is high-minded, which people will not think of, is sunbathing.
它在政治上非常激进。你的周围都是谈论慈善事业、建设乌托邦之类事情的人。而且我认为露营现在仍然稍微带有那种色彩——也许听到这里的露营者会被冒犯，但我认为它确实稍微带有那种调调，不是吗？有一种高尚的情怀。是的，也许吧，尽管现在有了“豪华露营”（glamping），不是吗？基本上就像住在非常高级的酒店里。我能接受豪华露营，但不能……是的，但我告诉你真正的情况。所以同样高尚的、人们不会想到的活动，还有日光浴。
So people who like camping and like going on these tours also believe that the sun is good for you. I mean, this is something completely new, isn't it? Because for so much of human history, paleness was prized because it was a sign of being part of the elite. Yeah. By the sort of turn of the 20th century, people are talking about sun baths and things like that. So Lucy Lethbridge in her book Tourists has a quote from what the writer Norman Douglas calls it, paganism and nudity and laughter.
所以喜欢露营和喜欢去这些旅行的人也认为阳光对你有好处。我的意思是，这完全是新鲜事物，对吧？因为在人类历史的大部分时间里，苍白都备受推崇，因为它是精英阶层的标志。是的。到了20世纪之交左右，人们开始谈论日光浴之类的事情。所以露西·莱瑟布里奇在她的书《游客》（Tourists）中引用了作家诺曼·道格拉斯（Norman Douglas）所称的“异教、裸体和欢笑”。
And D.H. Lawrence, she has a wonderful, very D.H. Lawrence quote where D.H. Lawrence has got a, from 1925, he has a woman who's sunbathing. Do you want to know? I mean, you can almost, it's like written by somebody, one of Lawrence's enemies doing a parody. Is it pre-epic? She feels that the sun is mating with her in his words.
还有D·H·劳伦斯（D.H. Lawrence），她引用了一段非常精彩、极具D·H·劳伦斯风格的话，其中劳伦斯描写了一个正在晒日光浴的女人，时间是1925年。你想听听吗？我的意思是，你几乎可以……这就像是由某个人、由劳伦斯的敌人写的一段恶搞。这是史诗前的吗？在她看来，用他的话说，太阳正在与她交配。
Well, she says, she slid off all her clothes and lay naked in the sun. As she lay, she looked up through her fingers at the central sun, his blue pulsing roundness whose outer edges streamed brilliance right pulsing with marvelous blue and streaming white fire from his edges the sun he faced down to her with his look of blue fire and enveloped her breasts and her face her throat her tired belly her knees her thighs and her feet yeah never changed dh lawrence never changed but D.H. Lawrence, never changed. But so, Dominic, anybody who's even faintly approximated to nude sunbathing, and I haven't,
嗯，她是这么说的：“她滑下所有的衣服，赤身裸体地躺在阳光下。她躺着，透过手指凝视着中央的太阳，他那蓝色的、脉动的圆形，外缘流淌着灿烂的光芒……脉动着奇妙的蓝色，边缘流淌着耀眼的白色火焰。太阳居高临下地注视着她，带着蓝色火焰的目光，包裹着她的乳房、她的脸庞、她的喉咙、她疲惫的小腹、她的膝盖、她的大腿和她的双脚。”是的，劳伦斯永远不变，D·H·劳伦斯永远不变。但是，多米尼克，任何稍微接近裸体日光浴的人——而我没有——
but- That's a terrible image, Tom. I once inadvertently sunbathed, I won't go into the details, but the tops, let's say the tops of my back thighs were inadvertently exposed. And by the end of the day, they were bleeding oh no sun had beaten down on them because if the sun doesn't normally see your skin it it burns very quickly so if people have never sunbathed before if if the the custom is is that you don't go into the sun what happens when you're suddenly a dh lawrence heroine and you're stripping off and the sun with its boiling great whatever masculinity yeah
那是一个可怕的画面，汤姆。我曾经无意中晒了日光浴——我不去细讲细节了，但上半身，比方说我后大腿的顶部不小心暴露了。到了一天结束时，它们都在流血。哦，不。阳光炙烤着它们，因为如果阳光平时照不到你的皮肤，它就会烧伤得非常快。所以如果人们以前从未晒过日光浴，如果习俗是不去晒太阳，那么当你突然变成了一个D·H·劳伦斯笔下的女主角，开始脱衣服，而太阳带着它那沸腾的、巨大的某种男子气概——是的，
masculinity is probing itself towards you i mean you're gonna burn aren't you no because you will have invested in the brand new 1930s produced um suntan lotion made by uh i knew you were gonna say that a man from l'oreal uh so the founder of l'oreal is a man called eugene schuler and he creates the first sun protection cream and calls it ombre solaire and it launched in 1935 but i'm pleased to say because we always like a bit of a bit of a laugh on this podcast to other people's misfortunes don't we tom that um a lot of people didn't put this on because it was presumably very expensive. And they put on homemade potions of their own devising
男子气概正向你探过来——我的意思是，你会晒伤的，对吧？不，因为你会买一瓶由……由欧莱雅（L'Oréal）的人制作的、全新20世纪30年代出产的防晒霜——我就知道你要这么说。欧莱雅的创始人是一个叫尤金·舒勒（Eugène Schueller）的人，他创造了第一款防晒霜，并将其命名为“Ombre Solaire”，于1935年推出。但我很高兴地说——因为我们在这个播客里总是喜欢从别人的不幸中找点乐子，对吧，汤姆？——很多人并没有涂这个，因为这可能非常昂贵。他们涂的是自己调制的自制药水，
or ones that were recommended in magazines. And a very popular choice was olive oil and lemon juice. Did it work? I don't believe it did. Or some people, there's one guy, again, from Lucy Lethbridge's book, she says, he writes,
或者杂志上推荐的药水。一个非常受欢迎的选择是橄榄油加柠檬汁。管用吗？我不认为管用。或者有些人——又是来自露西·莱瑟布里奇书中的一个人，她说，他写道：
it's very easy to prepare a homemade sun lotion, mix equal parts of olive oil and vinegar and add a dash of iron that's good that's going to appeal to the ladies isn't it yeah basically you dress you put yourself salad dressing um so it wasn't until 1956 that people discovered the link between being sunburned and skin cancer so people were completely and I think running right to the end of the 20th century, a lot of people just continue to be sort of almost willfully ignorant of the danger of excessive.
“制作自制防晒霜非常简单，将等量的橄榄油和醋混合，再加入少许铁质……”这很好，这会很吸引女士们，对吧？是的，基本上你是把沙拉酱抹在自己身上……所以直到1956年，人们才发现晒伤与皮肤癌之间的联系，所以人们完全——而且我认为一直延续到20世纪25年代末，很多人只是继续近乎故意地对过度暴晒的危险保持无知。
I suppose it's rather like smoking, isn't it? I suppose, yeah, it is. But obviously people are becoming, people are going on holiday in greater numbers. You've got air travel, obviously. I mean, it's extraordinary that so many people, for example example are going to mallorca before the second world war so 20 000 people um were going to mallorca a year in 1930 by 1935 40 000 people staying in hotels and 50 000 people were visiting on cruises a year because the famous famous person who goes there is Robert Graves.
我想这有点像吸烟，不是吗？我想是的，确实如此。但很显然，人们正在以更多的人数去度假。当然，你有了航空旅行。我的意思是，那么多人在第二次世界大战之前去马略卡岛，这太不可思议了——所以1930年每年有2万人去马略卡岛，到1935年就有4万人住在酒店里，每年有5万人乘游轮来访。因为去那里的一个名人是罗伯特·格雷夫斯（Robert Graves）。
Robert Graves. But I think even before he goes, I mean, actually, even though he would deny it because he would sort of say, oh, Mallorca was ruined after I moved there, I think the very fact that he's there is part of a trend, that people are going. Yes. So is it the kind of the pattern that you have people like Robert Graves and the Durrells and Paddy Lee Firmur and kind of bohemian middle class people going to live on Greek islands or Balearic islands and they settle there and the people with their salad dressing and all that kind of stuff right so cardamoli
罗伯特·格雷夫斯。但我想甚至在他去之前，实际上，尽管他会否认，因为他会说：“哦，我搬去之后马略卡岛就被毁了”，但我认为他去那里的这个事实本身就是一种趋势的一部分，人们正在前往那里。是的。所以这是一种模式吗？像罗伯特·格雷夫斯、杜雷尔（Durrells）一家、帕迪·李·费尔莫（Paddy Leigh Fermor）这样的一群波西米亚中产阶级去希腊岛屿或巴利阿里群岛生活，他们在那里定居，然后人们带着他们的沙拉酱和所有这些乱七八糟的东西……没错，所以卡达莫利（Cardamyli）——
where patrick lee firmer lived you know it's now a very very you know i mean it's not it's not a resort with concrete hotels but it's very busy in the summer guest houses full tons of people on the beaches you struggle to get a table in the tavernas it's exact and and actually the fact that patrick lee firmer lived there is part of the attraction. It's part of the attraction. Of course, all of this said, most people are not going on these kinds of holidays in the 1920s and 30s
帕特里克·李·费尔莫曾住过的地方，你知道，现在是一个非常非常……我的意思是，它不是一个布满混凝土酒店的度假胜地，但在夏天非常繁忙，宾馆住满了人，海滩上挤满了人，你在小酒馆里很难订到桌子。完全是这样。而且事实上，帕特里克·李·费尔莫曾住在那里正是吸引力的一部分。这也是吸引力的一部分。当然，话虽如此，在20世纪20和30年代，大多数人并没有去这种假期，
because it's not until 1938 that you have the Holidays with Pay Act. So that's something that the trade unions have been pressing for throughout the 20th century. And finally, basically, effectively, it's a complicated business, but effectively you get a week's holiday in Britain. Absolute, utter socialism.
因为直到1938年才有了《带薪休假法》（Holidays with Pay Act）。所以这是工会在整个20世纪一直在争取的事情。最后，基本上，实际上——这是一个复杂的事情——但在英国，你实际上获得了一周的假期。绝对彻底的社会主义！
Well, it isn't socialism. It's actually the Chamberlain government. Of course it is. Why didn't Stanley Baldwin? It seems a very Stanley Baldwin measure. Allow the working man to have a week's holiday. That's a very good question. I'll have to consider that, Tom.
嗯，这不是社会主义。这实际上是张伯伦（Chamberlain）政府做的事。当然是。为什么斯坦利·鲍德温（Stanley Baldwin）不……这似乎是一个非常斯坦利·鲍德温式的举措。允许工人阶级放假一周。这是个很好的问题。我得考虑一下，汤姆。
Maybe Stanley was not, maybe he had feet of clay. Yeah. Maybe he was distracted by his strenuous efforts to rearm before the Second World War, Tom. Maybe he was. Maybe he was.
也许斯坦利并非……也许他脚底有泥（指有致命弱点）。是的。也许他被他为第二次世界大战前重新武装所做出的艰苦努力分心了，汤姆。也许是的。也许吧。
Of course, Stanley Baldwin was a great believer in holidays. I mean, he basically took about six months holiday a year in Aix-les-Bains in France, where he just sort of strolled around and read books and smoked his pipe and didn't do any work. People would say Baldwin was terribly indolent when he was prime minister.
当然，斯坦利·鲍德温非常相信度假。我的意思是，他基本上每年在法国艾克斯莱班（Aix-les-Bains）度假大约六个月，在那里他只是闲逛、读书、抽烟斗，什么工作也不做。人们会说鲍德温在担任首相时极其怠惰。
Paul Rudstani is not emerging well from this podcast, which is unusual on the rest of his history. I think prime ministers should go off and don't mess things up. Don't do any work. I think there's a case to be made for that. That is the essence of conservatism tom well you've just said so anyway most people are not going to mallorca most people are doing two things one is they're going to the seaside resorts that we talked about in the last podcast so someone like blackpool blackpool is
保罗·鲁斯塔尼（Paul Rudstani）在这个播客中的表现不太好，这在《历史的余烬》里很不寻常。我认为首相就应该走开，不要把事情搞砸。什么工作都别做。我认为这很有道理。这正是保守主义的精髓，汤姆。好吧，你刚刚已经说过了。不管怎样，大多数人并没有去马略卡岛，大多数人在做两件事：一件是去我们在上一期播客中谈到的海滨度假胜地，比如黑潭（Blackpool）。黑潭到20世纪40年代每年接待
getting 17 million visitors a year by the 1940s absolutely extraordinary number of people and the people going to the lake district as well is that more middle class thing it's a very middle class thing right so the masses are definitely not going to the lake district yeah okay they're going to the beach because this is this is beatrix potter isn't it so she's presumably starting to i mean people going to the lake district that goes back to wordsworth and coleridge but you know the national trust yeah you're not going to sell that to people who are working in in mills in bolton or something Would you like to go walking in the Lake District? No, but it's part of the British tourist ecosystem, isn't it? It is. So it's kind of all emerging in parallel.
1700万游客，这是一个绝对惊人的数字。还有去湖区（Lake District）的人，那是更偏向中产阶级的活动吗？这是一个非常中产阶级的活动，对吧？所以底层群众绝对不会去湖区。是的，好吧，他们去海滩，因为这是——这是碧翠丝·波特（Beatrix Potter）的主题，不是吗？所以她大概开始……我的意思是，人们去湖区可以追溯到华兹华斯（Wordsworth）和柯勒律治（Coleridge），但是你知道的，国民信托（National Trust）……你不会把这推销给在博尔顿（Bolton）的工厂里工作的那些人。你会想去湖区徒步吗？不，但它是英国旅游生态系统的一部分，不是吗？是的。所以这一切都是并行出现的。
Yeah. But the big thing that has become part of the ecosystem is the holiday camp. I might be wrong about this, but I think this is something that in its popularity is unique to Britain. And it comes out of the cooperative, the collective ethos of the mid-20th century. So there had been camps with tents from about the early, about 1903 or so on, I think it is. 1906, there's a camp in Norfolk. There was a camp on the Isle of Man. But the man who is most associated this is um Billy Butlin so lots of our British listeners will have heard of Butlins Butlins which is even though it wasn't actually the biggest of the holiday camp chains it's the one that's most
是的。但已经成为生态系统一部分的重大事物是度假营（holiday camp）。我可能说错了，但我认为这是在普及度上对英国来说独一无二的事物。它源于20世纪中期合作主义、集体主义的精神。所以大约从早期开始，大约1903年左右，就有带帐篷的营地了，我想是这样的。1906年，诺福克有一个营地。马恩岛上也有一个营地。但与此最相关的人是——比利·巴特林（Billy Butlin）。所以我们的许多英国听众都听说过巴特林度假村（Butlins），尽管它实际上并不是最大的度假营连锁店，但它是最著名的。
famous the first one was at Skegness it was a Skegness because uh I went and you know I mentioned the this tour that we did going in a straight line across britain yeah did you go to butlin's and skegness we ended up in skegness no we didn't we didn't stay in butlin's i stayed in the worst hotel in britain in skegness it was awful you're going to blackpool next year so enjoy blackpool the walls were very very thin yeah and i was sleeping next to a group of i guess six people because their voices were all very penetrating, who were playing a kind of computer game, you know, lots of noises. Yeah. And then they started having group sex.
第一个营地在斯凯格内斯（Skegness），是在斯凯格内斯因为……我去过，你知道我提到过我们做的那次径直穿过英国的旅行，对吧？你去过斯凯格内斯的巴特林吗？我们在斯凯格内斯结束了行程。不，我们没有。我们没有住在巴特林。我住在斯凯格内斯英国最糟糕的酒店里，太糟糕了。你明年要去黑潭，所以好好享受黑潭吧。墙壁非常非常薄。是的。我睡在一群——我猜有六个人旁边，因为他们的声音都非常有穿透力——他们在玩某种电子游戏，你知道，有很多噪音。是的。然后他们开始群交。
Oh, no. Which went on until half past one. Then it stopped. I thought, oh, thank God. And then, obviously, the two who were left kicked off again. Oh, no. I had to get to sleep till three. That sounds terrible. I wish I'd gone to, thank God. And then obviously the two who were left kicked off again. Oh, no. I had to get to sleep till three. That sounds terrible.
哦，不。一直持续到一点半。然后停了。我想，哦，谢天谢地。然后，很明显，剩下的两个人又开始了。哦，不。我直到三点才睡着。听起来太糟糕了。我真希望自己去了——谢天谢地。然后，很明显，剩下的两个人又开始了。哦，不。我直到三点才睡着。听起来太糟糕了。
I wish I'd gone to Butlins. So that happened to me in the Hotel Niki in Sofia, Bulgaria. People who've listened to our previous podcast will be aware of my rendezvous with Boncho Todorov and the Bulgarian Football Union on my own grand tour in the 1990s. And we stayed in a hotel in sofia and there were a group of finnish soldiers who were serving with a un peacekeeping force in what is now north macedonia and they were on a weekend leave and we started and after we'd been to this match that
我真希望自己去了巴特林。这发生在我身上，在保加利亚索菲亚的尼基酒店（Hotel Nikki）。听过我们之前播客的人会知道，我在1990年代的个人“壮游”中，曾与邦乔·托多罗夫（Boncho Todorov）和保加利亚足球协会有过一次约会。我们住在索菲亚的一家酒店里，有一群芬兰士兵，他们在现在北马其顿地区的联合国维和部队服役，当时他们正在周末休假。我们开始……在我们去了这场邦乔·托多罗夫给我们弄到票的比赛之后，我们开始在酒店里和这些芬兰士兵聊天，他们非常非常友好、非常平易近人。然后他们的眼睛亮了起来，
boncho todoroff had procured us the tickets for we started we were chatting in the hotel to these finnish soldiers and they were very very friendly very personable and then their eyes lit up and that Boncho Todorov had procured us the tickets for, we were chatting in the hotel to these Finnish soldiers, and they were very, very friendly, very personable. And then their eyes lit up and they said, ah, excellent, the order has arrived. And the order was an order for some local ladies of the night that they had placed with a pimp. And they're all sharing the same room.
邦乔·托多罗夫给我们弄到票的比赛之后，我们开始在酒店里和这些芬兰士兵聊天，他们非常非常友好、非常平易近人。然后他们的眼睛亮了起来，他们说：“啊，太好了，订单到了。”这个订单是一份他们通过皮条客订购的当地夜场女郎的服务。而且他们都住在同一个房间里。
So again, it was the same. Were the walls very thin? Well, actually, I wasn't right next to them my friends were right next to them and my friends complained about halfway through the night they complained to reception and uh the finnish soldiers invited them to join in and they didn't um so yeah this is obviously a theme of both our holidays yeah but not really a theme of of the hits that's not going on in but we've gone off We've gone off piste again. So Billy Butlin, he was born in South Africa.
所以同样地，这也是一样的。墙壁很薄吗？嗯，其实我不在他们隔壁，我的朋友在他们隔壁。我的朋友在半夜左右向接待处投诉，芬兰士兵邀请他们一起加入，而他们没有……所以，是的，这显然是我们两人的度假经历中的一个主题，但并不是《历史的余烬》的主题。我们又跑题了。所以比利·巴特林，他出生在南非。
He came to Britain. He ended up as a sort of fairground entrepreneur. And he had the idea. He thought, what if we had basically accommodation at fairgrounds? And he builds his first camp in 1936. And straight away, you pay, I think it's three pounds, and you get a week's accommodation at this holiday camp, and you get all your food. And they have all these activities, but he notices on the first day that the guests aren't really, they're a bit diffident, and they're not kind of
他来到英国。他最终成为了一名游乐场企业家。他有了一个想法。他想，如果我们基本上在游乐场里提供住宿会怎么样？他在1936年建立了他的第一个营地。立刻，你付钱——我想是三英镑——你就能在这个度假营获得一周的住宿，并且包吃。他们有所有这些活动，但他注意到第一天客人其实并不是很……他们有点拘谨，没有真正地……
joining the activities. And he gets one of the staff to entertain the guests with jokes and sketches. Hidey-hi. Hidey-hi, exactly. Anyone who's seen the sitcom of the 1980s will know this. And it's with that that the Redcoats were born, the idea that the camp will have its own troop of entertainers who will kind of cajole you into all of these. Force jollity. Utter enforced jollity. Knobbly knees competitions, singing.
参与这些活动。他让其中一名员工用笑话和短剧来娱乐客人。“Hi-de-hi！”“Hi-de-hi”，没错。任何看过1980年代情景喜剧的人都会知道这一点。正因如此，“红大衣”（Redcoats）诞生了——这个概念是指营地将拥有自己的艺人团队，他们会用各种方式哄着你参与所有这些活动。强行制造快乐。绝对强行制造快乐。膝盖凸起比赛，唱歌。
To me, I mean, if it's that or the folk singing, for me, that's a very tough. Which would you go for? I'd probably choose butt lens over the folk singing. I think you would. What would you choose? I'd definitely choose butt lens. I've always quite fancied it.
对我来说，如果是在这个和唱民歌之间二选一，对真的很难抉择。你会选哪个？我可能会选巴特林而不是唱民歌。我想你会的。你会选什么？我绝对会选巴特林。我一直挺喜欢那里的。
I could see you as a red coat, Tom. I think you'd be an excellent red coat. Yeah. So lots of very, Jimmy Tarbuck was a red coat. Cliff Richard was a red coat. Jimmy Perry wrote Dad's Army. Michael Barrymore. Right, Michael Barrymore.
我觉得你可以当个红大衣，汤姆。我觉得你会是一个优秀的红大衣。是的。所以很多非常……吉米·塔巴克（Jimmy Tarbuck）曾是个红大衣。克利夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）曾是个红大衣。吉米·佩里（Jimmy Perry）写了《爸爸的军队》（Dad's Army）。迈克尔·巴里莫尔（Michael Barrymore）。没错，迈克尔·巴里莫尔。
Now, Ringo Starr used to play at Butlins. Before we joined the Beatles. He did indeed. Yeah. So you could see Ringo Starr. But anyway, Butlins is tremendously successful. He opens another one in Clacton and then bang, World War II happens. So that's a bit of a break.
林戈·斯塔尔（Ringo Starr）过去常在巴特林演出。在我们加入披头士乐队之前。他确实去过。是的。所以你可以去看林戈·斯塔尔。不管怎样，巴特林取得了巨大的成功。他在克拉克顿（Clacton）开了另一家，然后——砰——第二次世界大战爆发了。所以这算是一个小小的中断。
And what's interesting about World War II coming is that high-minded people are going to Germany on holiday. They're going to see concentration camps, aren't they? They go to Dachau. Yeah, it's astonishing. So the Nazis actually put on tours of Dachau. They are pretending that it's a kind of model camp. And people who are interested in kind of international fellowship, so people who are kind of pacifist and pacifist inclination,
而二战爆发有趣的一点是，思想高尚的人正在去德国度假。他们去参观集中营，不是吗？他们去达豪（Dachau）。是的，这太惊人了。纳粹实际上组织了参观达豪的旅行团。他们假装这是一个模范营地。那些对国际友谊感兴趣的人，也就是那些有和平主义倾向的人，
they're still going to Germany. So the things like the, the, the polytechnic travel association. So that group is still organizing tours. But they're not going to Dachau are they? No, but it's,
他们仍然在去德国。所以诸如理工学院旅行协会之类的事情。所以这个团体仍在组织旅行。但他们不是去达豪，对吧？不，但是，
they're going to German castles. It's people who are more on the right. Who are. No, I don't think that's right castles. I mean, surely it's people who are more on the right who are doing – No, I don't think that's right at all. I think quite the reverse. I think if you are on the right, firmly on the right – I mean, okay, not if you're far right, but if you're – so, for example, you might sympathize with Churchill.
他们去参观德国的城堡。是那些更偏向右翼的人……不是，我觉得那不对，城堡。我的意思是，这难道不是更偏向右翼的人在做的事吗——不，我觉得这完全不对。我觉得恰恰相反。我认为如果你在右翼，坚定的右翼——我是说，好吧，不是极右翼，但如果你是——例如，你可能会同情丘吉尔。
You're not going to go to Germany on a holiday. But if you're on the far right a nazi sympathizer so philip larkin we talked about philip larkin in the previous yes his awful parents his parents loved hitler's germany and they went on holiday there and um or ted heath actually went on holiday to germany and shook himler's hand at a nuremberg rally but he was he was appalled by it wasn't he he was appalled by it yeah he was on a cycling holiday he was indeed yes he was but cooperative so the cooperative tours i mean the cooperative that's obviously politically kind of progressive um they were still advertising rhineland and bavaria walking tours in august and september 1939 on this basis they said they will lead to the formation of friendships which
你不会去德国度假。但如果你在极右翼，是个纳粹同情者——所以菲利普·拉金（Philip Larkin），我们之前谈过菲利普·拉金，是的，他可怕的父母。他的父母热爱希特勒的德国，他们在那里度假。或者爱德华·希思（Ted Heath）实际上也去德国度假，并在纽伦堡集会上与希姆莱握手，但他对此感到震惊，不是吗？他对此感到震惊，是的，他是去骑自行车度假的，确实是的，他是。但合作社——所以合作社的旅行团，我的意思是，合作社在政治上显然是进步的——他们在1939年8月和9月仍然在宣传莱茵兰和巴伐利亚的徒步旅行，其依据是他们说，这些旅行将有助于建立友谊，
will break through the barriers of race creed and class and make for understanding and peace and amazingly these sort of travel groups were avid because obviously austria didn't exist anymore so they just listed all the austrian destinations under germany i suppose i don't know i mean i'm not attacking them tom you don't have to stick up for them i'm'm just stating a fact. Yeah, well, it's... You just don't want to hear anything against the sandal-wearing folk singers. Am I right? We are so conditioned to the morality and the politics of protest that I imagine then it was a more novel experience.
这将打破种族、信仰和阶级的障碍，促进理解与和平。令人惊叹的是，这些旅行团非常热衷于此，因为很显然奥地利已经不复存在了，所以他们干脆把所有奥地利的目的地都列在了德国名下。我想，我不知道，我的意思是，我不是在攻击他们，汤姆，你不需要为他们辩护，我只是在陈述一个事实。是的，好吧，它……你只是不想听到任何反对穿凉鞋的民歌手的话，我说的对吗？我们对抗议的道德和政治太习以为常了，以至于我想当时那是一种更新奇的体验。
First of all, you have to know how bad the Nazis are. And I accept that probably by 1939, people do know how bad they are. But then there's a certain kind of mental calculus required isn't there to think well we shouldn't go there because we by going there our money will be going towards yeah i think that's a fair economy but also i mean because you might say well we want to go there to show that we are still friends of course of course you might i mean you and i have both been to vladimir putin's russia haven't we yes so i mean it's not like but i mean people could well say oh you you would get happy to give him your you know your your money and support his economy and yeah and i very much felt i was you know it was a chance to meet russians that i wouldn't
首先，你必须知道纳粹有多坏。我承认，可能到1939年，人们已经知道他们有多坏了。但随后需要进行某种心理计算，对吧？去想，嗯，我们不应该去那里，因为通过去那里，我们的钱将流向……是的，我认为这是一个合理的经济考量。但同时，我的意思是，因为你可能会说，嗯，我们想去那里以表明我们仍然是朋友。当然，当然你可能会。你和我俩都去过弗拉基米尔·普京的俄罗斯，对吧？是的，所以，这并不像——但我的意思是，人们完全会说：“哦，你很乐意把钱给他，支持他的经济，然后……”是的，我当时强烈地觉得，这是一个结识俄罗斯人的机会，如果我不去的话，
otherwise have did you yes did you convert you convert them to your way of thinking? I didn't have to because we already agreed on the same, pretty much the same things. But I think it would have been a more complicated because more novel decision to make. And of course, the people who are doing this think that they are, by and large, they're doing the right thing. They absolutely think they are.
就绝对不会有这种机会。是吗？你把他们转化成你的思维方式了吗？我不需要转化，因为我们在相同的事情上已经达成了一致，几乎是完全一样的事。但我认为，这将是一个更复杂、更具开创性的决定。当然，做这件事的人认为他们——大体上——他们在做正确的事。他们绝对认为自己是。
We've talked in all these episodes about how travel and tourism has always been associated with the idea of broadening the mind, of making friends. It's always perceived to have had a kind of spiritual and ethical dimension. Going back, I suppose, to pilgrimages, if you really want to trace it all the way back. And I definitely think the people in the 1920s and 30s thought that they were doing their bit to avoid another continental war by making friends in Bavaria and all that sort of thing. Anyway, listen, we should take a break.
我们在所有这些剧集里都讨论过，旅行和旅游业一直与开阔眼界、结交朋友的想法联系在一起。它一直被认为具有某种精神和伦理维度。如果一直追溯的话，我想可以追溯到朝圣之旅。我绝对认为20年代和30年代的人们认为，通过在巴伐利亚结交朋友等方式，他们在尽自己的一份力来避免另一场欧洲大陆战争。不管怎样，听着，我们应该休息一下。
So when we come back, we're going to look at the post-war world. We are indeed. Very much moving on to your home territory. So that's very exciting. Sandbrook at its best. Don't miss it. With no pressure. See you after the break.
所以当我们回来时，我们将探讨战后世界。我们确实如此。非常正式地进入你的主场。所以这非常令人兴奋。最棒的桑布鲁克（Sandbrook）。千万不要错过。没有压力。休息后见。
I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to live tickets head to the rest of the entertainment.com that's
我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman）。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你获取每周娱乐新闻、评论以及少许娱乐圈八卦的首选。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐行业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想获得无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是
the rest is entertainment.com hello welcome back uh we are going on holiday again, are we not, Dominic? We're always on holiday. This podcast is one long holiday for me, Tom. One long, sunny holiday. And Second World War has ended. And I guess we are now entering the age of, well, we're kind of approaching the age of mass tourism, aren't we? We are. How does that develop? How long does it take for mass tourism to kind of become the phenomenon that we're familiar with today after the war? Depends what you mean by mass tourism.
therestisentertainment.com。哈喽，欢迎回来。我们又要去度假了，对吧，多米尼克？我们一直在度假。对我和说，这个播客就是一长假，汤姆。一个漫长、阳光灿烂的假期。第二次世界大战已经结束。我想我们现在正进入……嗯，我们有点接近大众旅游的时代了，不是吗？是的。这又是如何发展的呢？战后大众旅游需要多长时间才能变成我们今天所熟知的现象？这取决于你所说的大众旅游是什么意思。
So mass tourism in terms of people having holidays, just holidays very basically, once Britain is out of austerity at the end of the 1940s, but even actually during that, I mean, they've still got statutory holidays. So the late 1940s, very early 1950s is the absolute high point of the seaside resorts, I would say. Tens of millions of people going to these resorts. If you're a British soldier and you've been slogging your way up Italy or across France and Germany, I mean, maybe going abroad again is the last thing you want to do. Possibly. I mean, it completely depends on the individual. For some people, you definitely hear people saying that. But then for others, you hear people saying, I'd love to show my family Egypt or Sicily or... People who would not normally have seen Sicily or Greece or Egypt have seen it.
所以，就人们度假而言的大众旅游，非常基本意义上的度假——一旦英国在1940年代末摆脱了紧缩政策，甚至实际上在紧缩期间也是如此，我的意思是，他们仍然享有法定假日。所以1940年代末、1950年代初是海滨度假胜地的绝对最高峰，我想这么说。数以千万计的人涌向这些度假胜地。如果你是一个英国士兵，曾在意大利一路拼搏向上，或者穿过法国和德国，我的意思是，再次出国可能是你最不想做的事。也许吧。我的意思是，这完全取决于个人。对有些人来说，你绝对会听到有人这么说。但随后对于另一些人，你会听到有人说：“我很想向我的家人展示埃及、西西里或……”那些通常看不到西西里、希腊或埃及的人现在看到了。
Exactly right. But at first, they're not doing that because not really until the 1960s does the age of package tourism start in earnest so for about 15 years after the end of the second world war the big things are still the holiday resorts and the holiday camps so we talked about billy butlin before the break butlin opens loads of camps in the 1940s and 1950s so air and mosney atney at Bognor Regis and Minehead. And these are appealing to thousands and thousands of people. So at the big camps, you will have 10,000 people there at a time. And there are all these amazing statistics about, you know, Butlin will be getting through 4 million eggs a week
完全正确。但起初他们并没有这样做，因为直到20世纪60年代包机旅游时代才真正全面开始。所以在大战结束后的约15年里，主要项目仍然是度假胜地和度假营。所以在休息前我们谈到了比利·巴特林，巴特林在40年代和50年代开了大量的营地。所以有艾尔（Ayr）、莫斯尼（Mosney）、阿特尼（Atney）、博格诺里吉斯（Bognor Regis）和明海（Minehead）。这些吸引了成千上万的人。所以在大营地里，你一次会有1万人在那里。有所有这些关于……你知道，巴特林每周要消耗400万个鸡蛋，
or 240 tons of pork chops or whatever it might be. And these camps now have this incredible ecosystem of games. They have all these prizes. So Lovely Legs Prize, Knobbly Knees, we mentioned before. Shiniest Bald Head Prize. Now, we both know who would have won that. Anastasius. Anastasius.
或者240吨猪排，诸如此类。这些营地现在拥有令人难以置信的游戏生态系统。他们有所有这些奖项。所以有迷人美腿奖、膝盖凸起奖——我们之前提到过。最闪亮光头奖。现在，我们俩都知道谁会赢得这个奖。阿纳斯塔修斯（Anastasius）。阿纳斯塔修斯。
Yeah, he would have absolutely aced that. Who we talked about in our Justinian Theodora podcast. Because he was complimented, wasn't he, on the baldness of his head. Yeah, the gleam. The silvery gleam. By Roman writers. So you're doing that now. One other thing you have now in the 50s that a lot of people would not have had before the war is cars.
是的，他绝对能轻松搞定这个。我们在查士丁尼与狄奥多拉的播客中谈到过他。因为他曾被称赞过，不是吗？称赞他头顶的秃顶。是的，那道银色的光芒。被罗马作家称赞。所以你现在正在做这件事。50年代你拥有的另一件事，是许多人在战前所没有的——汽车。
So you have caravanning. Caravanning is a massive success story in the 50s and 60s. Mr. Toad had a caravan, didn't he, in The Wind in he in the wind and the wind he did but then he gets a car yeah but a lot of people um do it the other way around after the second world war they get a car and then they get a caravan and these are not mr toad style gypsy caravans they are sort of as people call them kind of bungalows on wheels so um they are sort of very shiny and very fancy driving very very slowly down single lane roads and it's also this is probably the point at which places like you talked about the lake district before the break devon and cornwall are swamped with caravan
所以你们有大篷车。大篷车在50和60年代是一个巨大的成功故事。查德先生有一辆大篷车，对吧，在《柳林风中》他在……在《柳林风中》他确实有，但后来他弄了一辆车，是的，不过很多人嗯在第二次世界大战后反其道而行之，他们先买一辆车，然后买一辆大篷车，这些可不是查德先生那种吉普赛大篷车，它们有点像人们所说的轮式平房，所以嗯它们非常闪亮，非常时髦，在单车道公路上开得非常非常慢，这也是，这大概是像你之前在休息前提到的湖区、德文郡和康沃尔郡被大篷车
sites and the roads now i know the a303 is a particular concern for you tom because of stonehenge this is the point at which people are complaining about the roads to the West Country being blocked by caravans. But then the big innovation, I mean, I know you've been waiting for this. It is the story of Vladimir Reitz. So Vladimir Reitz is a white Russian emigre, very excitingly. He was born in Moscow. His mother fled to Western Europe in 1928 and left his father behind. He never saw his father again.
营地淹没的时间点，现在我知道A303公路由于巨石阵的原因是你汤姆特别关心的，这就是人们抱怨通往西南部公路被大篷车堵塞的时期。但随后的重大创新，我的意思是，我知道你一直在等这个。这就是弗拉基米尔·赖茨（Vladimir Reitz）的故事。所以弗拉基米尔·赖茨是一位白俄难民，非常令人兴奋。他出生在莫斯科。他的母亲于1928年逃往西欧，留下了他的父亲。他再也没有见过他的父亲。
He arrives in London in 1936, and he speaks Russian, Polish, and German, but not a word of English. And he ends up becoming a Reuters journalist. And Vladimir Reitz is, to this podcast, what Thomas Cook was to the last one. He is the pioneer, the inventor. Because what he does is he basically invents the overseas package flight so thomas cook is leading not just britain but the world is this something specific to britain or is this being developed elsewhere as well
他于1936年抵达伦敦，会说俄语、波兰语和德语，但不会说一个英语单词。他最终成为了一名路透社记者。而弗拉基米尔·赖茨对这个播客而言，就像托马斯·库克对上一个播客一样。他是先驱，是发明家。因为他做的事基本上是发明了海外包机旅游，所以托马斯·库克不仅引领了英国，还引领了世界，这是英国特有的现象，还是其他地方也在发展呢？
no i think rights develops it before anybody else does actually i mean i think maybe the germans are just behind because the germans are always stereotypically are the the competition aren't they for the sun loungers and well stereotypically they're always um half an hour ahead aren't they yeah the competition get their towels out yeah but in fact in fact we were developing them just ahead of the germans i mean that's very i think so i think so maybe maybe if we have german listeners they can write in and correct me i mean i imagine actually these things often happen roughly the same time but i'd imagine just because britain is recovering perhaps that little bit quicker than germany i mean obviously
不，我认为赖茨比任何人都先开发出来，实际上，我的意思是，我想也许德国人只是落后了，因为德国人总是刻板印象中的竞争对手，不是吗，为了争夺躺椅？嗯，刻板印象中他们总是嗯提前半小时，不是吗？是的，竞争对手先把毛巾拿出来，是的，但事实上，事实上我们开发得比德国人早一点点，我的意思是，这非常……我想是这样的，我想是这样的，也许，也许如果我们有德国听众，他们可以写信来纠正我，我的意思是，我实际上想象这些事情通常大约在同一时间发生，但我猜只是因为英国恢复得可能比德国稍微快一点，我的意思是，显然
then is later overtaken by germany i mean who knows anyway reitz was a reuters journalist and he went to corsica where his friend was running a water polo club for some white Russians in Corsica. And he basically has this eureka moment where he thinks, I could do a bit of a Thomas Cook. I could book them onto a plane, bring them over, put them up. And he goes back home and there are all kinds of regulations that make this really difficult. So what he has to do is charter his own DC-3 planes, and then he basically needs
后来被德国赶超了，谁知道呢。无论如何，赖茨是一名路透社记者，他去了科西嘉岛，他的朋友在那里为一些白俄人经营一家水球俱乐部。他基本上有了这个“尤里卡”灵感时刻，心想，我可以像托马斯·库克那样做一点业务。我可以为他们预订飞机，把他们接过来，给他们安排住宿。他回到家里，发现有各种各样的法规让这变得非常困难。所以他必须做的是包租自己的DC-3飞机，然后他基本上需要
to get tourists onto them. And because of the incredible sort of complicated bureaucratic regulations that are designed to protect the existing airlines, the state-owned or state-funded airlines, he is only given the permission by the Ministry of aviation if he does this purely for students and teachers so they advertise he advertises his plan in the teacher's world magazine the nursing mirror and the new statesman but again this this kind of progressive exactly worthy exactly so yeah fascinating people who are sick of the folk songs and the sandals now have another another option another outlet yeah and he basically says you pay me £32 and I'll fly you out to Corsica and you'll be under canvas initially, but you'll get unlimited food, unlimited wine, loads of sun, beach. Brilliant.
让游客坐上飞机。由于旨在保护现有航空公司（国有或国家资助的航空公司）的那种令人难以置信的复杂官僚法规，航空部只在他是纯粹为学生和教师服务的情况下才授予他许可，所以他们做了广告，他在《教师世界》杂志、《护理镜报》和《新政治家》杂志上为他的计划做了广告，但同样，这种……这种进步的，完全是高尚的，完全是这样的，所以是的，那些对民歌和凉鞋感到厌烦的迷人的人们现在有了另一个选择，另一个出路，是的，他基本上说你付给我32英镑，我用飞机把你送到科西嘉岛，起初你会住在帆布帐篷里，但你会有无限量的食物、无限量的葡萄酒、大量的阳光、海滩。太棒了。
And they go. They go from Gatwick, the 180 of them. When they get to Corsica, there's a brass band waiting for them and villagers with garlands of flowers. And they stay in the Camp Franco-Britannique, Calvi, where they have a dance floor and a bar and all this stuff. And the rest is history, Tom, because after this, Wright says, Company Horizon, they have camp in Mallorca, they have camps in the Costa Brava. And they become more and more. And they have club.
然后他们出发了。他们从盖特威克机场出发，180人。当他们到达科西嘉岛时，有一支军乐队在等着他们，村民们拿着花环。他们住在卡尔维的法英营（Camp Franco-Britannique），那里有舞池、酒吧和诸如此类的东西。剩下的就是历史了，汤姆，因为在此之后，赖茨的公司“地平线”（Horizon），他们在马略卡岛有营地，在布拉瓦海岸有营地。他们变得越来越多。他们有俱乐部。
They have reps. Do you know who he interviewed? Get this. Who Vladimir Wright interviewed as a travel rep for Horizon and turned him down. Didn't think he'd be very good in the 1950s. Alan Wicker. You're actually pretty close. It's the future Tory MP and rake Alan Clark.
他们有代表。你知道他面试了谁吗？听着这个。弗拉基米尔·赖茨作为“地平线”的旅游代表面试了谁并拒绝了他？在20世纪50年代认为他不会表现得很好。阿兰·威克（Alan Wicker）。你其实挺接近的。那是未来的保守党议员兼花花公子阿兰·克拉克（Alan Clark）。
Okay, that's very improbable. Yeah, that's very improbable. Yeah, that's very improbable. I know Corsica is kind of France-ish, but it is France. The sense I have of Britain and France, say in the 50s and early 60s, is that Britain is absolutely, it's all about knobbly knees competitions and handkerchief, knotted handkerchiefs on on stopping pates from going red whereas france it's effortless chic uh it's bikinis oh i'm so glad you mentioned that tom because did you think i would come to this podcast without information about the history
好吧，这太不可思议了。是的，这太不可思议了。是的，这太不可思议了。我知道科西嘉岛有点像法国，但它就是法国。我对英国和法国的印象，比如说在50年代和60年代初，是英国绝对的，全都是粗膝盖比赛和打结的手帕，系在手帕上以防止晒伤变红，而法国则是毫不费力的时髦，嗯，是比基尼。哦，我很高兴你提到这一点，汤姆，因为你以为我会没有关于历史的资料来参加这个播客吗？
of the bikini no so you're great you haven't got information about the bikini have you i haven't just inadvertently allowed you to reveal everything you know about the bikini i i very much enjoyed researching this as you can imagine um so the bikini was invented by a man called louis rayar in 1946 and it was unveiled at the the pissine molitor which was a swimming pool in paris he got a showgirl called micheline bini. You see, that is the difference. We have butlins. They have showgirls advertising newly invented bikinis. So swimsuits had always been, you know, enormous.
比基尼没有，所以你太棒了，你没有关于比基尼的资料，对吧？我没有无意中让你透露你对比基尼的全部了解吧？正如你所想象的那样，我很享受研究这个过程，嗯，所以比基尼是由一个叫路易·雷亚尔（Louis Réard）的人在1946年发明的，它是在巴黎的一个游泳池——莫利托游泳池（Piscine Molitor）亮相的。他找了一个名叫米什琳·比尼（Micheline Bernardini）的歌舞女郎。你看，这就是区别。我们有巴特林度假村。他们有歌舞女郎来宣传新发明的比基尼。所以泳衣一直以来都是，你知道的，巨大的。
And I should say that Dominic at this point is gesturing. I am gesturing to myself. In a very French manner. I am. Swimsuits had always been enormous and made of wool and just generally very unsexy. Yeah. But French designers were sort of competing in 1946 to invent something befitting an age that had come out of the war and wanted to sort of let its hair down and stuff. So there are two different designers.
我应该说多米尼克此时正在做手势。我正在对自己做手势。以非常法国的方式。我是。泳衣一直以来都是巨大的，由羊毛制成，而且总的来说非常不性感。是的。但法国设计师在1946年左右竞相发明一些适合一个刚经历过战争、想要放松一下等等的时代的服装。所以有两个不同的设计师。
There's one called Jacques Haim, and he advertises his bathing. he calls it the world's smallest bathing suit and he calls it the atom and louis rayard you know invents what we know now as the bikini it's all about nuclear weapons isn't it it is he says his advertising slogan is smaller than the world's smallest bathing suit and he names it the bikini after the bikini atoll where the Americans have just done an atomic test. So it's very much, it's a swimsuit for the atomic age. Yeah. So you've got the atom and then you've got a swimsuit named after a nuclear explosion. It's enormously successful, though not interesting in America. Because they're too puritanical.
有一个叫雅克·海姆（Jacques Heim），他宣传他的泳衣，他称之为世界上最小的泳衣，并称之为“原子”（Atom），而路易·雷亚尔，你知道的，发明了我们现在所知道的比基尼。这全关于核武器，不是吗？是的，他说他的广告标语是“比世界上最小的泳衣还要小”，并以比基尼环礁命名它，美国人刚刚在那里进行了原子弹试验。所以这非常、非常是原子时代的泳衣。是的。所以你有了“原子”，然后你有了以核爆炸命名的泳衣。不过它取得了巨大的成功，虽然在美国并不感兴趣。因为他们太清教徒了。
Too puritanical. So it's the 60s that it takes off in America, is it? With the Beach Boys and itsy bitsy teeny weeny yellow polka dot bikini yeah and the sort of beach boys surf culture and all of that stuff you were asking about california in the last episode i mean the 60s is the heyday of the californian beach scene and bikini is i guess a part of that but meanwhile obviously the british are beginning to desert their holiday camps in the 60s and to go abroad. So by 1971, British tourists are taking 4 million holidays abroad. So you get places like Benidorm.
太清教徒了。所以它是到60年代才在美国流行起来的，是吗？伴随着海滩男孩乐队（Beach Boys）和《黄色圆点比基尼》（Itsy Bitsy Teenie Weenie Yellow Polka Dot Bikini），还有海滩男孩的冲浪文化以及所有这些东西。你在上一集问过关于加利福尼亚的事情，我的意思是，60年代是加利福尼亚海滩文化的鼎盛时期，而比基尼我想是其中的一部分。但与此同时，英国人显然在60年代开始抛弃他们的度假营地去国外旅游。因此到1971年，英国游客在海外度假的人数达到了400万。所以你有了像贝尼多姆（Benidorm）这样的地方。
So Spain basically, isn't it? Which at this point is still under Franco. Franco needs cash. He needs hard currency because his economy is so sclerotic. And one way of kick-starting his economy is to go for tourism in a big way. And Franco, in alliance with Spanish property developers and sort of landowners and things, they basically turn a lot of these very sleepy, pretty fishing villages into concrete black pools, basically.
所以基本上就是西班牙，对吧？当时西班牙仍然在弗朗哥的统治下。弗朗哥需要现金。他需要硬通货，因为他的经济太僵化了。启动他经济的一种方法是大力发展旅游业。弗朗哥与西班牙房地产开发商、土地所有者等结盟，基本上把许多这些非常安静、美丽的渔村变成了一片片混凝土巴特林，基本上就是这样。
And Benidorm is a famous example. So Benidorm in 1957, south of Valencia, it has fewer than 3,000 people living in it. That's 1957. By 1960, it's getting 30,000 British and German visitors every August. It has 300 new buildings. It has 30 high-rise blocks of flats, 34 hotels and four cinemas, and however many thousand English breakfasts being served a day. And this is almost an overnight transformation of huge stretches of the Spanish coastline, but also an overnight transformation for lots of ordinary Britons, many of whom would never have aspired to go abroad. They could never have dreamed of emulating the Grand Tour that we did in the first episode, or even the Thomas Cook tours of episode two. So there's a great moment actually, Tom, 1970, the former deputy Labour leader, George Brown, is addressing a meeting at a Labour club in the 1970 election. And he says, only a couple of years ago at the Labour club in my constituency,
而贝尼多姆就是一个著名的例子。因此，1957年的贝尼多姆，位于巴伦西亚南部，常住人口不到3000人。那是1957年。到1960年，每年8月都有3万名英国和德国游客涌入。它拥有300栋新建筑、30栋高层公寓楼、34家酒店、4家电影院，以及每天供应的成千上万份英式早餐。这几乎是对西班牙大片海岸线的隔夜改造，但也是对许多普通英国人的隔夜改造，他们中的许多人以前从未奢望过出国。他们做梦也想不到能效仿我们在第一集里做过的大环游，甚至第二集里的托马斯·库克旅行。所以这是一个很好的时刻，汤姆，1970年，前工党副领袖乔治·布朗（George Brown）在1970年大选的一次工党俱乐部会议上发表讲话。他说，就在几年前在我选区的工党俱乐部，
you'd have seen a poster advertising the annual outing it used to be a day at blackpool or new brighton or skegness where do you think people go now and at that point the secretary of the labour club gets up and he says oh this is a great opportunity to advertise our annual outing we're actually going for a week at the mediterranean and that you know i mean that's interesting that he says the mediterranean because he doesn't clearly doesn't know the name of the resort they're going to it is conscious that it's somewhere hot with sun and sand and sangria and I suppose the film that holds a mirror up best to this kind of great sociological process of change would be carry on abroad wouldn't it oh yeah good choice Tom very good choice 1972 carry on crew yeah so for our overseas listeners we'll just find this weird obscure babble now but uh british listeners will probably have seen the
你会看到一张海报，上面宣传着年度郊游活动，以前是一天去黑普尔、新布赖顿或斯凯格内斯，你觉得现在人们去哪里？就在那时，工党俱乐部的秘书站起来说，哦，这是一个宣传我们年度郊游的好机会，我们实际上要去地中海待上一周，你知道，我的意思是，有趣的是他说的是“地中海”，因为他显然不知道他们要去的度假胜地的名字，他只知道那里是个有阳光、沙滩和桑格利亚汽酒的炎热地方，我想最能反映这种伟大社会学变革过程的电影大概是《海外继续疯狂》（Carry On Abroad）吧？哦，是的，好选择，汤姆，非常好的选择，1972年的“继续疯狂”剧组，是的，所以对于我们的海外听众来说，现在会觉得这是一段奇怪、晦涩的胡言乱语，但英国听众可能看过这部电影，会知道它。
film will be aware of it so the carry-on film are these sort of um sort of farcical bawdy uh this sort of institution isn't it they do a carry-on film a year or so. Same team. Yeah, kind of bras snapping and... Oh, exactly. Letchers going... And all that kind of stuff. Sid James' Laugh, which I know you'll remember that time. It's very, very 70s, very 60s, 70s. So they go to what is billed as a paradise island
所以“继续疯狂”系列电影是那种，嗯，闹剧式的、低级趣味的，这种机构，不是吗？他们大约一年拍一部“继续疯狂”电影。同样的团队。是的，有点像内衣搭扣断裂，还有……哦，完全是这样。色狼们发出……诸如此类的事情。西德·詹姆斯（Sid James）的笑声，我知道你会记得那个时代的。这非常非常70年代，非常60年代、70年代。所以他们去了一个被称为地中海天堂岛的地方，
in the Mediterranean called Elles Bells. And they get there. The hotel isn't finished. All the electrical fittings explode. The sand comes out to the taps rather than water um all of these kinds of things they behave very badly chaos okay absolutely hilarious chaos tom hilarious antics they all end up in prison but of course the reason that this is funny and resonant is because this was completely recognizable
名叫埃尔斯贝尔斯（Elles Bells）。他们到了那里。酒店还没建好。所有的电气设备都爆炸了。水龙头里流出来的不是水而是沙子，嗯，所有这些乱七八糟的事情。他们的行为非常糟糕，混乱，好吧，绝对是滑稽的混乱，汤姆，滑稽的滑稽动作。他们最后都进了监狱。但当然，这之所以滑稽且引起共鸣，是因为这完全是可以辨认的。
yeah to thousands if not millions of british i, I can well remember going on a holiday in the 1980s with my parents to Crete and getting the phone call literally as we were on our way out of the door. So our bags were packed and the tour company saying, your hotel's not quite finished. So the first week of your two-week holiday, you'll have to stay at this other hotel. So we stayed at this other hotel. And then on on friday they said why don't you go and
是的，对于成千上万甚至数百万的英国人来说。我完全记得在20世纪80年代和父母一起去克里特岛度假，就在我们出门的那一刻接到了电话。我们的行李已经打包好了，旅游公司说，你们的酒店还没完全建好。所以你们两周假期的第一周，你们得住在另一家酒店。所以我们住在了那家另一家酒店。然后在星期五他们说，为什么你们不去新酒店开车看看并查看一下呢，我们就去了，结果那是一个建筑工地，我的意思是简直可笑，绝对可笑，根本没有任何质量控制。直到70年代初，BBC的度假节目和ITV的《祝你玩得开心》（Wish You Were Here）才真正出现，在这些节目中，我的意思是，70年代初的部分节目，BBC的度假节目和ITV的《祝你玩得开心》，他们在节目中，我的意思是，这些节目的一部分意义在于它们在监督所有这些公司，事实上“地平线”是较好的公司之一，但它们在监督那些本来就……我的意思是监管太可怜了。
drive out to the new hotel and check it out and we went and it was a build it was a complete building site i mean just laughable absolutely laughable there was no quality control at all and it was actually only at the beginning of the 70s really that the bbc did its holiday program and itv did wish you were here in which they were i mean part of the beginning of the 70s really that the bbc did its holiday program and itv did wish you were here in which they were i mean part of the point of those programs was they were holding all these companies to account and actually horizon was one of the better companies but they were holding companies that otherwise were pretty much i mean the regulation was pitiful okay so that's really changed then hasn't it because travel programs now are all about basically
好吧，那真的变了，不是吗？因为现在的旅游节目全都是关于……基本上是让你感到嫉妒。是的，但那时候，它更像是一个消费者监督机构。这其中有一点成份，但肯定是因为人们去旅游时非常紧张——没有互联网，除了几本薄薄的小册子之外，你对要去的地方没有任何信息，到达那里后只能依靠旅游代表。你会坐上飞机，周围每个人，你知道，穿过机舱里的烟雾，大家都在抽烟斗，你下飞机。
making you feel jealous yeah but back then it was it was much more kind of consumer watchdog there was an element to that but there was definitely because of course it was incredibly nerve-wracking for people to go on i mean there's no internet you'd have any information about the place you're going other than some flimsy brochure and and relying on the travel rep when you get there you would go on the plane where everybody you know through clouds of smoke on the plane smoking their pipes you get off through clouds of smoke on the plane because everybody was smoking. Yeah, smoking their pipes. You get off into the heat. You don't speak a word of Spanish or Greek or something.
穿过机舱里的烟雾，因为每个人都在抽烟。是的，抽着烟斗。你走进热浪中。你不会说一句西班牙语、希腊语或其他语言。
And then you're sort of all herded on buses to this hotel, and you've got no idea really what's awaiting you. But it must have been amazing. Oh, incredible. I mean, you read the diaries and letters and things of people who went to, let's say, Ibiza in 1969 or 1971. And they say, you know. They'd never experienced heat like it, I guess. Heat and the smells and the food.
然后你们所有人被赶上大巴去这家酒店，你根本不知道等待你的是什么。但那一定很神奇。哦，太不可思议了。我的意思是，你读那些去过，比方说1969年或1971年的伊比沙岛的人的日记、信件之类的东西。他们说，你知道的。他们以前从未经历过这样的高温，我想。热浪、气味和食物。
Obviously, at first, people are very suspicious of the food. There are wonderful stories of groups. There's a lovely story about a group of Derbyshire miners who take their own beer and their own tinned food to Italy. Because they think, you know, obviously, you can't eat the local food it's going to be awful foreign mark yeah foreign mark exactly but by the 70s what you definitely get in britain is all of those places we've been talking about before like blackpool and the holiday camps they are in the most hideous decline so at butlins for example all the days of the knobbly knee competition they're still trying to do them but butlin's have had terrible trouble with it's so cheap you see that
显然，起初人们对食物非常怀疑。有一些关于旅行团的精彩故事。有一个很棒的故事，讲的是一群德比郡的矿工带着他们自己的啤酒和罐头食品去意大利。因为他们认为，你知道，显然，你不能吃当地的食物，那会是糟糕的外国货，是的，外国货，完全是这样。但到了70年代，你在英国绝对能看到的是，我们之前谈论过的所有那些地方，比如黑潭和度假营，它们正在经历最可怕的衰落。所以在巴特林度假村，例如，所有那些粗膝盖比赛的日子，他们仍然在努力办，但巴特林的麻烦太大了，你看，因为太便宜了。
they've had teenagers going and sort of uh rowdy youngsters and it's basically become there's a lot of stories about violence and drunkenness and this sort of thing butlin's have banned single young men from going yeah in an attempt to clean up and reclaim their family basically because because the package tour to spain isn't that much more expensive exactly it's so cheap so companies like horizon are doing it you know what did we say it was 32 pounds in uh 1950 or so i mean okay butlins is a fair bit cheaper but it's not out of reach for working class people in the 1970s. If you're in work, if you've got a steady wage, you can aspire to go to
有青少年去那里，还有一些吵闹的年轻人，它基本上变成了……有很多关于暴力和酗酒以及这类事情的故事。巴特林度假村已经禁止单身年轻男性进入，是的，为了清理并重新夺回他们的家庭度假定位，基本上是这样，因为去西班牙的包机并不是贵得离谱。完全是这样，太便宜了。所以像“地平线”这样的公司在做这件事，你知道，我们刚才怎么说的？在1950年左右是32英镑，我的意思是，好吧，巴特林度假村要便宜一些，但对于20世纪70年代的工人阶级来说并不是遥不可及。如果你有工作，如果你有稳定的工资，你就可以渴望去西班牙呆上一周甚至两周。
Spain for a week or even two weeks. So Dominic, the development of the tourist industry in the 70s, to what extent, say in 2022, is the tourist infrastructure descended directly from that is this when tourism as as we have experienced it through our lives as people experience it now is is that basically where the foundations are being laid no actually i would say there's a great break and i think the great break is the internet and the 19 of course yes of course um so i think the difference is that the 70s is very much in the tradition that goes back to thomas cook going back to the you know the victorians um and and there's always a middleman there is always a you know there's a sort of there's a collective ethos you go in a
所以，多米尼克，70年代旅游业的发展，在多大程度上，比方说在2022年，旅游基础设施是直接从那个时期传承下来的？这就是我们一生中所经历的那种旅游业——人们现在所经历的那种——这基本上是奠定基础的时候吗？不，事实上，我认为有一个巨大的断裂，我认为这个巨大的断裂是互联网和19……当然，是的，当然，嗯，所以我认为不同之处在于，70年代非常符合追溯到托马斯·库克、追溯到维多利亚时代的那种传统，而且总是有中间人，总是有，你知道的，有一种集体精神，你去一个……
you know there's a sense of a group you know if you were staying at one of these big concrete hotels as as i did as a child in the early 1980s, lots of kind of group activities laid on. There was an expectation you'd be in the kids' club. There was a sort of flamenco evenings, excursions by coach from the hotel, all that sort of stuff. And I think that world really began to break up in the 1990s. Once people are booking their own flights individually
你知道，有一种团队感，如果你像我一样在20世纪80年代初作为孩子住在这些大型混凝土酒店里，有大量为团队安排的活动。人们期望你会参加儿童俱乐部。有一种弗拉明戈之夜，从酒店出发的长途汽车远足，所有这些类似的东西。我认为这种世界在20世纪90年代真正开始瓦解。一旦人们开始单独预订自己的航班，
because cheaper flights, deregulation of the aviation industry once they're you know i mean of course those that industry still exists but it's there are so many challenges to it now right and i think for younger people the idea that you would walk into we mentioned lun poly because of the polytechnic association the idea that you would walk into a high street travel agent and from an incredibly flimsy brochure and about six lines of text, choose a hotel to spend a week or two weeks and then put yourself completely in the hands of these gatekeepers, I guess, which is the travel company and its representatives.
因为更便宜的航班、航空业的放松管制，一旦他们，你知道的，我的意思是，当然那个行业仍然存在，但现在它面临着这么多的挑战，对吧？我认为对于年轻人来说，走进我们之前提到的“朗波利”（因为理工学院协会而被称为Poly），走进一家高街旅行社，从一本极其单薄的小册子和大约六行文字中，选择一家酒店度过一两周，然后完全把自己交托给这些守门人——我想就是旅游公司及其代表。
I mean, you would never do that now, would you? So Thomas Cook's gone bust, hasn't it? So, yes, Thomas Cook Group went bust in 2019 into compulsory liquidation. Thomas Cook Holidays was spun off as a successor and has been trading for a couple of years. That's a great shame, isn't it? Well, it still exists with the same name.
我的意思是，你现在永远不会那样做了，对吧？所以托马斯·库克破产了，对吧？是的，托马斯·库克集团在2019年破产清算。托马斯·库克假期作为继承者被分拆出来，并一直在交易几年。那真是太遗憾了，不是吗？嗯，它仍然顶着相同的名字存在。
I suppose. Yes, I suppose. The interesting question, I suppose, I mean, there was tons of stuff we were meant to be talking about and we haven't talked about Eviva España, the Sylvie Rathammer hit. I'm quite relieved about that. But now that we've mentioned it, we don't need to mention it again. We haven't really talked about Heidi High
我想是的。是的，我想是的。有趣的问题，我想，我的意思是，我们本来有很多事情要谈，但我们没有谈论《万岁西班牙》（Eviva España），西尔维·拉塔马（Sylvie Vartan）的热门歌曲。我对此感到相当欣慰。但既然我们已经提到了它，我们就不需要再提了。我们没有真正谈论过“海蒂·高”（Hi-de-Hi）
and its role in the culture of the 1980s, but maybe it's important to leave people wanting more, isn't it? It always is. It always is. I suppose the interesting questions are, what are the sort of the themes that run through this and actually i think there's an extraordinary sense of continuity in the way that people understand travel and holidays don't you that sort of sense
及其在20世纪80年代文化中的角色，但也许让人意犹未尽是很重要的，不是吗？一向如此。一向如此。我想有趣的问题是，贯穿其中的主题是什么？实际上我认为人们对旅行和度假的理解有一种非凡的连续性，不是吗？那种……
of well i'd say first of all the thing that's really striking is class divide yes definitely always been there and always will be so that is absolutely kind of soldered through, going right the way back to the 17th century. And your choice of holiday now says an enormous amount about your class position, doesn't it? Because choice is almost infinite now. And what you choose says so much about you. But I guess also this extraordinary tradition of teetotal percenters basically constructing the kind of the fabric of the tourist industry.
嗯，首先我要说的是，真正令人惊叹的是阶级分化，是的，绝对的，一直存在，也永远会存在。所以这绝对是根深蒂固的，一直追溯到17世纪。你现在选择的度假方式很大程度上说明了你的阶级地位，对吧？因为现在的选择几乎是无限的。而你的选择充分说明了你。但我想还有这种极其清教徒式的先驱们基本上构建了旅游业架构的传统。
Well, that sort of high-mindedness to holidays, that's something that before we got into this subject, I hadn't gauged the extent to which the Grand Tour, for example, there was a high-mindedness to the grand tour the idea about you know educating yourself as people now um say so so sort of um sensoriously yeah yeah and but we still have that don't we there's still a sort of sense that when you go if you're a sort of educated middle class person you're expected to go on a holiday that will broaden your horizons in which you will see, I don't know, indigenous people weaving some nice rugs or something like that. We went on a family holiday to stay with friends in America who had a wonderful place by the sea. And we just stayed in this house and, you know, had wonderful American food and just
嗯，那种高尚的度假态度，在我们涉足这个主题之前，我没有料到大环游（Grand Tour）在多大程度上具有那种高尚性——关于自我教育的想法，正如人们现在……嗯，说得那么……嗯，爱说教的，是的，是的。但我们现在仍然有这种态度，不是吗？仍然有一种感觉，当你去旅游时，如果你是一个受过教育的中产阶级人士，你被期望去一个能开阔视野的度假地，在那里你会看到，我不知道，土著人民在编织一些漂亮的毯子之类的东西。我们曾进行过一次家庭度假，去美国拜访朋友，他们在海边有一个很棒的地方。我们只是留在这个房子里，你知道，吃着美味的美食，只是……
kind of lazed around. And I remember my daughters being stunned that there wasn't an obligation at some point to go and see a temple on a hill in mid you know midday but did you feel cheated that you weren't able to do that no i loved it i really loved it but maybe that's because going to see a temple in boiling heat is work to you whereas to a lot of people it's not work it's it's fun no it's always fun but i just realized i did have a kind of i it came to me that my holidays had always been faintly puritanical which is why i found the puritanical strain throughout you know this
到处闲逛。我记得我的女儿们感到震惊的是，在中午时分，竟然没有义务去参观山上的寺庙。但你有没有觉得自己被剥夺了无法做到这一点的权利？不，我喜欢它，我真的很喜欢它。但也许这是因为在沸腾的热浪中去参观寺庙对你来说是工作，而对许多人来说这不是工作，这是乐趣。不，这总是很有趣。但我只是意识到我确实有一种……我突然明白，我的假期一直带有淡淡的清教徒色彩，这就是为什么我发现贯穿我们一直在看的这一切的清教徒倾向如此有趣，因为这里有很多自我认同感。
everything we've been looking at so interesting because there's quite a lot of self-recognition there yeah well i think what's really fascinating is that holidays are not just meant to be fun they're meant to be good for you and that idea about health as well um which goes back to the sort of to brighton and to bath and then to the those awful german 19th century spas that's still there but i think also and this is as true of butlin's as it is of the my lord going off in 1720 there's a there's a fear of boredom which also hangs over it yeah and anxiety you know you think you work so hard you're you know so tired you need a break but even as you're heading off there's this nervous what if i'm bored you know what if there's nothing to do what if i get fed up i need to book and i need to urgently book a sea kayaking
嗯，我认为真正迷人的是，假期不仅是为了好玩，它们还被认为对你有益。关于健康的想法也是如此，这可以追溯到布赖顿和巴斯，然后到19世纪那些可怕的德国温泉疗养地，这种想法仍然存在。但我认为，这也是巴特林度假村和1720年出游的英国贵族所共有的，有一种对无聊的恐惧也笼罩着这一切。是的，还有焦虑，你知道，你觉得自己工作太努力了，你，你知道，太累了，你需要休息，但就在你出发的时候，有一种紧张感：“如果我感到无聊怎么办？你知道，如果没有事情可做怎么办？如果我厌烦了怎么办？”我需要预订，我需要紧急为我们预订一次海上皮划艇
trip for us or whatever it might be. Exactly. You know, so that's, you know, the Butlins expresses that just as much as the Boswell going off to see Rousseau. It does indeed. But Tom, you've got a holiday coming up, haven't you? I mean, this hasn't put you off your holiday, has it? End of September, yeah. Where are you going?
之旅，或者其他什么。完全是这样。你知道，所以，巴特林度假村和博斯韦尔（Boswell）去看卢梭一样，都表达了这一点。确实如此。但是，汤姆，你接下来要度假，对吧？我的意思是，这没有打消你度假的念头吧？九月底，对吧。你要去哪里？
Are you able to tell the listeners? Going to Corfu. Oh, very nice. Is this the cricket? Playing cricket and then staying on for two weeks after. Very nice. The key question, as listeners to the last podcast will know, is this. Are you going to drink any seawater?
你能量出听众吗？去科孚岛。哦，非常好。这是去看板球比赛吗？打板球，然后在那之后多呆两周。非常好。正如上一期播客的听众所知，关键问题是这个。你要喝海水吗？
I think, well, I probably will because I'll, you know, I'll probably fall out of a boat or something, inadvertently gulp it down. But not deliberately, no. I'm not going to. Okay. Well, I mean, that's the thing that is, I think that and those terrible treatments and the gas injections, I think I could definitely live without that on holiday.
我想，嗯，我可能会，因为我会，你知道，我可能会从船上掉下来什么的，无意中吞下去。但不是故意喝的，不。我不会去喝。好吧。嗯，我的意思是，这就是我认为的，我想那个和那些可怕的治疗方法以及注射气体，我想在度假时我绝对可以没有这些。
I mean, maybe there'd be a market for a kind of retro holiday agent. That's a brilliant idea. That would provide you with all these terrible- Tom, that, forget the podcasting. That is how we will make millions. Well, maybe we could do it under the aegis of the podcast the rest is history period period holidays period holidays we you can have a choice of you can go
我的意思是，也许会有一种复古旅游代理的市场。这是一个绝妙的主意。那将为你提供所有这些可怕的——汤姆，忘掉播客吧。这就是我们将赚取数百万美元的方法。嗯，也许我们可以在播客的庇护下做这件事——“一切皆为历史”句号句号度假村，“一切皆为历史度假村”。我们可以让你有选择，你可以去
on a grand tour you can go to to brighton and drink seawater you can go to a german german spa yeah or you can do the kaiser's fjord trip before the first world war maybe or a butlin's i've been to a butlin's holiday i've been i've filmed to butlin's holiday camp well i think this is this is a very exciting kind of spin-off from the from the podcast this is great watch this space very very exciting the blind beak didn't work out but this is the future we haven't quite finished because tomorrow we're going to do something slightly different and yet also at the same time similar we're going to go back to uh the ancient world and see if there was anything that approximates to what we would understand as holidays, tourism in the ancient world.
进行一次大环游，你可以去布赖顿喝海水，你可以去德国的德国温泉，嗯，或者你可以在第一次世界大战前进行一次德皇的峡湾之旅，或者去巴特林度假村。我去过巴特林度假村的假期，我去拍摄过巴特林度假村。嗯，我认为这是播客的一个非常令人兴奋的衍生产品，这很棒，拭目以待，非常非常令人兴奋。“盲目喙”（The blind beak）没有成功，但这才是未来。我们还没有完全结束，因为明天我们要去做一些略有不同但同时又类似的事情。我们要回到古代世界，看看是否有任何类似于我们所理解的假期、古代世界的旅游业的东西。
So we will see you then. Bye-bye. All right. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishtertainment.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以我们到时候见。拜拜。好的。拜拜。感谢收听《一切皆为历史》。如需收听加长节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。那是 restishtertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。